I thought the first rule of Hong Kong
well they let the spy in
let me tell you something boys that's
where dreams come true oh damn Hong Kong
is a place
[Music]
all right so you were just telling us
about some amazing thing that happened
yeah dude so this guy in Oregon Eugene
Oregon right empty empty empties out his
uh family shared bank account and out of
like anger and rage and took it all out
and he went on a high speed per suitcase
in the freeway and was throwing two
hundred thousand dollars whoa I'm
talking about big bills too hundred a
hundred dollar bills out of the window
so the car the cars immediately stopped
and got out of the car and started
[__] grabbing money dude which all of
us would do yeah well others would do
but we would all do that so they caught
the guy he went to jail you know I was
good but then the families uh asking for
the people who went out and got the
money to return the money please yeah
right
who's gonna [__] return the money
like that's honestly that's your son's
dumbass idea to do that so I thought
people oh you were nice was it wait so
who is it the Father the like who what
who are the other shared people who's
the person that did it was it the sun
the sun the Sun so he's mad at his
parents he's mad at his parents took the
money out of the shared bank I mean it's
the parents fault that he has full
access to the family yeah exactly how
rich is this guy that he could just
throw away 200 G's like that he's quite
an idiot does he have more money on the
other side where it's like pennies to
him I mean if you're in a shared bank
account with your family you're probably
you probably don't have a normal sense
of money
and also like what did you do yeah to
the kid to piss him off like just to
just throw away all that kid's just a
rotten [__] apple he sounds like a
[__] sounds like a piece of [__] piece
of [__] yeah that is a nut that's a
crazy but also a great guy if you're one
of the people that caught the money oh
people caught like there's people that
are reported like that I caught like two
thousand dollars worth imagine it's
coming up anyway and that's 200 000 I
get throughout what if we're what if
we're just judging this guy and it's one
of those things we're like oh you guys
ever care about is money well if that's
what you care about Mom and Dad I'll
show you
you agree [__] we need a
background check on this guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah that kid sucks has anybody
brought any of it back there could be a
good Christian again if this is like you
know California
Oregon Oregon I mean you know Eugene
Oregon they're very like I think some
people gave it back
I felt guilty spending a thousand
so I decided to give my 200 back yeah
so to be clear every one of us would
stop and pick up money yeah yeah [__]
yeah like money is flying out of the car
I'm pulling over if I see all these
people slowing down we're like we're
creating a wall yeah yeah let me tell
you something right now my guy okay I
was [__] at school and some kid
[__] lost five dollars and I found it
and I put it in my pocket and then they
stopped the class we're not going to
lunch until somebody replaced those
brings that five dollars back and the
kids crying and I knew the [__] kid
I sat there and I was like do you have
it nope you should have learned a lesson
if we check your pockets
make me I'll call the principal right
now I have right
s and so they never you could have just
been like that's mine yeah no no it was
obviously they didn't tell me to check
my pockets I was like very convincing I
was like dude I was a very good actor
yeah did you have the five dollars like
no that was the concerned person too
it's like dude who has
[Laughter]
detective everyone we gotta go to lunch
dude it's [__] Johnny's money
and like I would get really angry at the
tears like all right calm down calm down
that's okay we'll find it's almost fine
you get closer to Johnny
matter of fact go to lunch go calm down
wolf federalism
[Laughter]
I want Josh
I could buy everything what dude
does anybody one of Cheetos or no hot
Cheetos with cheese
five bucks you know what I mean I'll get
you a lot of it like 50 75 cents yeah I
mean a dollar with [__] extra cheese
so to answer your question I wouldn't
give a goddamn dime back finders I lived
on this American rule dude Finders
Keepers losers what if you found
somebody's wallet and had their idea in
it you know how many times I've done
that
no if I were to find I did return
somebody's wallet because I do remember
like it happened to me
and it sucked yeah and that really
sucked and I remember going like [__]
are you kidding me and it was
devastating like I just like had
everything and I was like [__] that so
one time I did find somebody's wallet
I'm like oh
and it had money but it was just like I
remember that moment I looked at this
address on his ID and it showed up and I
gave it to him that's cool he was happy
he didn't he didn't give me [__] but he
was happy though he couldn't believe it
either he's like dude are you [__] no
way give me a couple hugs and I'm like
yeah yeah it's all good dude you have a
daughter
I had a lot of friends with uh
questionable moralities right so one one
of them found a wallet at the mall he's
like oh [__] look at this [__] you know
and then he takes the money and I'm like
Okay cool so you're gonna return it goes
no I want them to know that I took it so
I'm like what are you gonna do so he
throws it away and he goes I don't want
their identity to be stolen okay that
guy that's smart
so I'm like so you're carrying you're
caring because you don't want their ID
credit cards and all those things to be
stolen but I'm like dude you could take
the cash and give the rest to the
security and then I'm just like what the
[__] oh my God are you serious have you
have you guys ever been to like a club
where there's bottle service and then
there's a guy that starts throwing like
dollar bills everywhere really yeah it's
like a thing yeah my brother does that
yeah yeah so a lot of people do that but
it's really bad taste to like pick the
money up really why because you look
like a crazy guy because you look like a
bar or something dude I'll give a [__]
I'll be on my knees and just pick him up
but it's supposed to be for the the bar
the waiter later it's really yeah it's
supposed to be for the house basically
oh okay I've been in strip clubs where I
like I had friends who were like showing
off their wealth and I'm like
I step on it or something and I just
[__] drag it
there's a lot of strippers I cut my like
the strip right we caught a ice look
crab in the money what are you doing
foreign
thing
that was great for grabbing money dude
that [__] was fun have you seen those
dollar guns that you can make it rain
yeah I never seen them before I want to
use them
oh yeah yeah that's pretty fun I never
threw money like that I would like to do
it at a strip club you never made it
rain yeah we're like and then just make
it rain in the butt the butt just
I think I respect money too much I don't
know if I could do that yeah that's the
thing dude I'm very you have to have an
attitude of like [__] money I don't give
a [__] but I'm like I don't know that
that's not honest to what I feel that's
not me you know what the circles I just
feel so [__] fake there dude you know
they tell you what you want to hear and
I just feel so like you're like you
don't want me for me I know you don't
like it you don't even know me that's
what I would say though yeah as you cry
yeah I'm like no I don't want to dance
with you I don't even know who I am I
don't know I don't even know what I like
I was getting a lap dance and that's
when I was like I'm never coming to
strip club again I was like getting a
lot I really like the girl she's like
gave me a lap dance and I'm like in it
and I'm just looking at her whatever and
then for some reason I'm just wondering
is she liking this yeah yeah yeah so
then I look at the mirror and I see the
mirror and she's legit just like
and I remember going like yeah I'm not
doing this this is like so awkward
because it's a job and she's just like
she was you could just see it in her
face like it's like what time am I off
like what is going on this small dick is
so
and I'm just like this is all I was the
worst and I was like never again this is
just so awkward like for me yeah so I
just I just go with prostitutes now
that's a real [__] deal dude
why are you messing around why are we
getting blue balls here that's my
mindset if I'm gonna go if I'm gonna go
to strip club I'd rather not go to a
strip club and like if I'm gonna indulge
in services like that you might as well
just get a process you might as well
jizz you might as well do the real thing
you're gonna spend money some dudes dude
yeah yeah that's true that's true though
some strippers do end up giving you that
Liberty yeah have you guys ever been to
where you go They're gonna like you
though right have you guys ever like
heard of this magical place uh it's
called Hong Kong Hong Kong my buddy was
talking about how did you guys know wait
Hong Kong down south yeah TJ Hong Kong
oh no
it's one of those I gotta like take a
shot before you tell me I thought the
first rule of Hong Kong
well they let the spy in
let me tell you something boys that's
where dreams come true oh damn Hong Kong
is a place
magical place where you can when
anything goes you know what I'm saying
oh there Money Talks oh I see one of
those kinds you know what it is it's
like all these people they're like
all these [__] active Shooters are
like not getting [__] and they're like
send them to Hong Kong send them to Hong
Kong all right let's sit in Hong Kong
not the country but like the one in
Tijuana
looking [__] fine there should be a
fund by the government for this you know
the things you can do for a hundred
dollars oh God I mean
your dreams will come true
you're a [__] King you know what I'm
saying you see things the things that
I've seen was just like wow I grew up
like
like really fast up there just like with
one walk walk around like whoa I became
like five years older
I'm a seasoned vet now are you
definitely like after like an hour
you're like this is rough
there's a lot going on here so when you
walk in what's the first thing you see
first thing you see right you walk in
it's like three levels and then the
fancy Asians are at the top you know the
fancy oh yeah they got the fancy Asians
over there at the top yeah they're
[__] straight Maniacs dude they're
doing some [__] nasty stuff up there
and then uh you walk in and there's just
strippers normal strip club it's
beautiful you know they're greeting you
in I can puss in your face you're just
like oh lovely yes [__] my fantastic
you're walking past that then in the
back it gets needy greedy
he gets nasty dude that's when things
are like things are being used stuff is
going on so it's time to rest you gotta
just figure it out the rest when the
cameras turn off I'll tell you some
[__] stories dude but what I saw back
there was definitely on like okay
okay you're gonna walk in a virgin and
leave wow dude yes dude exactly you walk
in and you're like just from seeing it
you get AIDS you're busting nuts just
seeing it yeah you're just like oh [__]
everybody's just yeah you gotta Hong
Kong
[Music]
foreign